Se muestra la gráfica de la línea
"2y" más "3x" igual a 7.
Encuentre la intersección en "x".
Bueno, recordemos que la intersección en
"x" es el valor de "x" cuando "y" vale 0,
aquí lo podemos ver.
Y nos podemos más o menos dar cuenta, de
que este punto parece estar un poquito más
arriba del 2, pero sin llegar al 2.5, para
encontrar el valor exacto, veamos la ecuación.
"2y" más "3x", como queremos la intersección en "x",
esta "y" la vamos a sustituir por un 0,
2 por 0 más "3x" igual a 7.
2 por 0 es 0, nos queda "3x" igual a 7 y si
dividimos todo entre 3,
esto entre 3 y esto entre 3,
nos queda que "x" es igual a 7/3.
A lo mejor se ve un poco complicada esta fracción,
si la transformamos a decimal,
pero recuerden que esto es igual a 6/3 más 1/3 y,
¿cuánto es 6 entre 3?
pues es 2, esto es igual a 2 enteros 1/3,
que es más o menos lo que se alcanza a ver,
una tercera parte de aquí arriba de este 2.
Otra forma de verlo, es que este 3 cabe dos
veces en este 7 y nos sobra 1 y ese 1 hay
que dividirlo entre 3, por lo que nos queda
de nuevo 2 enteros 1/3.